you can remove video backgrounds filler
words and background noise clone your
voice and in one click you can use the
power of AI to skip the hard part of
editing videos the six best AI tools for
turning one long video into 10 viral
Clips their AI analyzes your video to
identify the most compelling hooks
extracts relevant and juicy highlights
from different parts of the video and
seamlessly rearranges them into cohesive
viral short videos
the world is changing and it has never
been a better time to be creating
content sure competition is rising but
so is technology and with the invention
of AI tools it's now possible to get a
lot more content done in less time and
in this episode of the think media
podcast I'm going to be sharing with you
six of my favorite tools for repurposing
content across YouTube shorts and social
media the six best AI tools for turning
one long video into 10 viral Clips
number one Munch dot AI content
repurposing done smart so what Munch
does is Munch extracts the most engaging
trending and impactful clips from your
long form videos using state-of-the-art
generative Ai and marketing analytics
when we've tested Munch we just actually
put the YouTube link into munch it
actually takes like 20 30 40 minutes and
then it kicks out whatever format we
want do we want Square vertical
horizontal clips and it uses trending
keywords it listens to what you're
saying in the videos and the final
result is exactly what you want there
can be captions there's different
templates to it it's a very cool tool we
have tested this one and it definitely
has a lot of Promise number two video
dot AI this is AI based content
repurposing and all of these in the list
are similar but there's differences to
all of them as well the goal here is to
save 90 percent of time and effort now
there's a free version of this and a lot
of these tools will link them all in the
show notes so you can check them out but
the free version actually gives you 75
minutes of upload Time free every single
month so imagine if you had a 10 minute
video you could upload seven of them
basically or link seven of them to the
tool and it's going to kick out viral
short clips and it'll have captions on
there there's different templates
different emojis some cool features on
video.ai number three a Opus clip their
promise one long video 10 viral Clips
created 10 times faster Opus clip is a
generative AI video tool that repurposes
long videos into short videos with one
clip now there's a few features that
they've trademarked that kind of
explains what you're getting with this
tool they have clip genius and so their
AI analyzes your video to identify the
most compelling hooks extracts relevant
and juicy highlights from different
parts of the video and seamlessly
rearranges them into cohesive viral
short videos so as we talk about this
these tools are still being developed
we've personally gotten some good
results with them but sometimes we have
to massage the clip a little bit fix the
end point the out point you think about
not just where does the clip start but
should we cut anything out of it should
we rearrange it and so clip genius all
these tools are being worked on and all
these tools are being developed is
really cool because the goal is that you
have a cohesive final product product
that you can then upload across your
platforms and that people can actually
follow along with and is very engaging
and trims the fluff and all the above so
what they actually did was they did
hundreds of double blinded studies with
creators and creators who used Opus clip
5xed their video views in addition to
everything I've said about Opus clip
here so far what it also does is it
generates a score to show you the
potential virality of each clip and
that's based on other viral videos and
I'm guessing that that comes down to
topic certain topics are going to go
more viral on social media than others a
lot of times if there's more broad
appeal if it's something that a lot of
people can relate to or how shareable it
is now they also have predictive AI that
analyzes moving faces and ensures that
you and your guests face will always be
in the center of the video frame so
again think about this if you're sitting
on camera somewhere and you're clipping
a horizontal video into a vertical video
the AI is framing you up properly now it
also analyzes the video captions they
found that on average highlighted
keywords increase video watch Time by 65
percent and their AI analyzes your video
and automatically adds relevant emojis
and highlights valuable content and on
average emojis increase views by 42 so
picture a viral clip a viral video clip
that has emojis popping up on the video
along with the captions perhaps you've
seen other content creators doing this
and the goal of all these tools is yes
you could sit down and manually create
Clips like this in a video editing
software but it would actually take
hours and so literally we're trying to
get 10 50 100 x a return on our time by
using powerful tools like this to turn
our long form videos into viral Clips we
still have three more tools but one of
the reasons why I want to share all of
this with you is so that you also can be
thinking about what's possible and what
are the features and benefits that
you're looking for as you test out these
different tools we're in the process
process of testing all of these with you
none of them I think is a clear winner
yet because they all are hustling to add
new features to develop their features
to make sure their features work and so
some of the other features that you
could be looking for and here's a few of
the other features that Opus clip has it
has Auto resizing again that's going to
be framing your video square or vertical
Auto transitions Auto captions 1080p
resolution sometimes you won't get the
highest resolution on the free version
but once you pay you get the higher
resolution you have filter word removal
which is really cool there's different
tools like some of the ones we're about
to cover that can take out your ums they
can take out stumbles you could add a
specific word that maybe you repeat all
the time and you don't know you're doing
it you could have a customized brand kit
trendy templates and AI relay out so
Opus clip has a lot and that is one that
our team has really fallen in love with
Nolan has used it I mentioned in episode
two of this podcast series Opus clip is
what Jeff Moore's has been using at
Oceanside church and full disclosure
sometimes there is some frustrating
times when it doesn't kick out the best
results but these are also just tools
and they're tools in the hands of a user
that's still thinking creatively still
thinking about how's the video opening
and so Opus clip is definitely one I
recommend checking out number four
descript descript is an all-in-one video
audio editor as far as I know the script
I think has been around longer than any
of these other tools and it does a lot
more than just turning long form videos
into viral Clips you can remove video
backgrounds filler words and background
noise clone your voice and in one click
you can use the power of AI to skip the
hard part of editing videos and just one
of their features is clip creation so
you can quickly create clips for all
social platforms using templates and
subtitles the scripts captioning is
known to be incredibly high quality and
the style of it is something you've
probably seen before if you're looking
for a video editor that does is all the
things and a lot more than just clip
creation I think the script is
definitely worth looking into number
five is autopod now this tool is just
for Adobe Premiere but it is a game
changer their promise is automatic
editing for video podcasts and shows and
the goal is to Save hours in your weekly
production time in Adobe Premiere with
their pack of plugins I think it was
Omar Al takori who first showed me this
tool when he was editing a multi-angle
video shoot that was an interviewer a
conversation among multiple people when
you shoot a video like that you end up
throwing all four of those angles into a
Premiere timeline and then you go
through the tedious process of choosing
who to cut to when to cut to them and if
it was a hour-long conversation the edit
could take at least an hour if not two
or three enter autopod you simply
install the plugin click go basically
and in a matter of minutes or even
seconds it edits through the entire
multi-camera shoot knowing who's talking
when they're talking and picking out all
of the shots for you literally it turns
three hours of editing into three
minutes now of course it's always a good
idea to review to watch it back maybe
you watch it back at one and a half or
two x speed just to see if there was any
edits you want to change or any
differences that you want to make but
there's no doubt about it this is a real
Time Saver now autopod also has a social
clip Creator a very easy to use tool
that allows you to just create Clips out
of different parts of your video right
from the Premiere Pro timeline and
what's cool about this is it'll help you
create the different resolutions very
easily you want to make a square clip do
you want to make it vertical do you want
a 1080p do you want it 4K and then
finally it also has a jump cut editor so
you can actually input the decibel cut
off of your particular microphone and
create cuts and so the use case of this
would be if you shoot a video like I'm
doing right now a talking head video
that ends up being like one 25 minute
video in your Premiere Pro timeline but
I have different starts and stops and
reshoots and gaps in between my content
well the jump cut editor is going to cut
out all of the downtime and you can even
tell it by decibel Point how quickly you
want to cut after that final word and so
YouTube editing sometimes almost has
like a hyper fast feel to it or if you
want a little bit more margin again
these are leveraged tools it's helping
you just go faster and of course after
you use the jump cut editor you need to
go in and maybe delete some parts that
you repeated yourself and review the
footage but everything about autopod is
about saving you time and helping you go
faster and so if you're an Adobe
Premiere user or you know somebody who
is or somebody on your team is no doubt
about it you should check out autopod
now number six is stream yard now this
one might surprise you because stream
yard is a tool that allows you to
seamlessly multi-stream to all the
different social media platforms but
what's cool is inside of stream yard is
also a shorts and reels Creator so on a
big level stream yard is a web-based
platform that we actually love at think
media for going live we often go live to
one of our YouTube channels one of our
Facebook groups when we do a challenge
it's how we go live inside of the
Facebook group it allows us to bring on
multiple people a lot of times Melissa
and I will co-host videos we're using
stream yard if we want to bring on
guests or interviews or do video
podcasts it has a lot of those features
but one of the things they've included
inside of stream yard is the ability to
create and publish shorts and reels from
the videos that are captured on the
cloud of stream yard and so what you do
is you actually connect your stream yard
account to your YouTube account to your
Instagram account to your Facebook reels
account to your Tick Tock account and
then you go to your library which is
web-based and then you can trim a clip
anywhere from five to sixty seconds make
some adjustments to it and then just
click export and it upload it to the
various platforms now I would say this
tool is still in its early stage it's
kind of basic at this point you're able
to cut out these clips it's not the main
point of stream yard but I'm excited as
they continue to develop it and it
certainly is a great way if you don't
have other video editing software or
you're limited in Tech and you're a
one-man one-woman show when it comes to
creating content it's a very leveraged
additional tool to maybe you know there
was something great I said on that live
stream and I just want to quickly share
that everywhere else stream yards got
you covered now you can always check out
stream yard at
streamwiththink.com and for its perfect
record feature and its live streaming
features you've probably heard us
recommend it all the time here at think
media we absolutely love them and you
can also check out all of these tools
linked up in the show notes below some
of those links are probably affiliate
links and if you want to see not just
these but every tool that we use at
think media
thinkmediatools.com we actually recently
we updated that page and when you're
building a digital business as a digital
entrepreneur as a content creator
eventually you actually need a lot of
different tools maybe you have a CRM
you're building an email list you've got
the way that you're live streaming now
these days you're using AI tools to help
you go faster there's video editing
there's money management and financial
tools and so if you're curious out of
all the tools that we've tested over
years and now multiple think team
members and think faculty testing these
tools that's our goal is to figure out
the ones that are good to figure out the
ones that are actually useful that are
actually worth the money and worth the
investment now if you want to check out
stream yard you can always go to stream
with think.com and you've heard us talk
about stream yard before for all of its
other features so it's a little bit
different than these other tools right
now we personally are of course using
stream yard for streaming all the time
for a perfect record feature many think
media team members are using autopod
saving a lot of time we are using Opus
clip Munch and video we're kind of
combining them Opus clip seems to be our
favorite but we've got our eyes on all
the platforms because they are making
updates and improving them and they're
all definitely useful and so if you want
to see a summary of everything that I've
talked about in this episode you can
actually go to
thinkmediatools.com we'll also link that
up in the show notes as well and so if
you're looking for tools that will help
you go faster a lot of really cool free
tools and many of these have free
versions or of course eventually when
you want to get that 1080p resolution or
take it to that next level of how many
outputs you can do or the best premium
features and templates and all that
stuff there's a lot of different things
to check out so your One-Stop shop is
thinkmediatools.com we just updated that
page with all of the favorite tools
we've been using and things we've been
testing and of course we'll link that
stuff in the show notes as well for you
to check out now if you're not
subscribed you definitely want to
subscribe because part four in our
YouTube productivity series is all about
our 12-step video checklist list that
will help you actually be more
productive next time you're filming a
YouTube video and if you missed part one
and two definitely check out links in
the show notes to check out the entire
YouTube productivity tips series you're
gonna love all the different episodes
and if you got value out of today's
episode it would mean the world to me if
you rate review and like this episode
wherever you watch or listen to it I
appreciate you so much sending you
massive love and respect today and I
can't wait to connect with you in the
next episode